okay yeah okay
hello thanks for showing up welcome to
audio in standard C++ this is what we're
going to talk about today in the next 90
minutes so we're gonna look at you know
whether there actually is any audio and
C++ today and what you can do with it
and then the next section actually can
ask who here is actually professional
audio kind of developer or has done
audio stuff before okay
three people so okay so for you the
first half an hour will be quite boring
this is like the basics you know all
this for the rest this is we're going to
explain how audio actually works like on
a very low level so that we all know
kind of what you're talking about here
so we're going to talk about sound waves
about how do you represent an audio
signal digitally in a computer how audio
i/o works how do you communicate with
your sound card and then a little bit
about kind of how you build on that for
some functionality and then kind of the
meat of the talk is the kind of second
half here which is the proposal for
actually an audio api for the c++
standard library so we're going to look
at the API design what classes are in
there what interfaces are there you're
going to look at I'm gonna give you an
update on the latest state of this
proposal which is r2 which is still in
progress and then we're gonna look at
the reference implementation then we're
gonna do a live demo so I'm going to
show you some actual running code
because we have implemented this this is
where it usually all goes wrong if you
do live demo serving talks so you know
don't expect stuff to work and then kind
of use more slides about like what's
next and um yeah so let's start so what
do you see it's esterday all notebooks
all desktops all phones all the phones
that you have in your pocket all the
stuff at your phone on your table have
audio input and audio output a lot of
embedded audio devices also have audio
at least audio output even if you have
like a microwave is probably going to
give you a sound at some point so I
would say that most or a lot of devices
run C++ actually are capable of 4000 and
it's part of their functionality and
actually audio is really really
important for a lot of areas where C++
is used so obviously if you have any
kind of user interface you know with
some buttons or whatever dialogues and
you want to have some sound to reinforce
you know your interaction with that user
interface obviously if you have software
to make calls or to communicate in other
ways typically you will have audio in
there as well obviously if you're
actually playing back sound if the whole
point is like streaming and song from
the internet or just playing back a file
then this is also audio games are I'm
thinking ball about sound imagine how
boring a video game would be if you
wouldn't have any sound and then there
is this pro audio domain which is kind
of what I do which is music software and
software for music production and
software for music performance
so basically suffer from musicians and
producers and performers and then
there's other areas like creative coding
if you have installations or if you have
art a lot of time there's some code
running there which and there's also
audio in there audio is used for
research for science and also audio is
great for education you know when you
know kids done how to program it's
really cool if they can make sound with
their program that's that's pretty good
again you can't even code like a simple
video game without it so what I would
say is that audio is one of the basic
aspects of human-computer interaction
right so imagine like you know one of
the simplest games for example something
like this which has been around for a
lot longer than I am alive
so imagine what do you need to implement
this you need a screen that you can draw
into so you need to do fix you need some
kind of user input like keyboard mouse
or joystick or buttons or something like
that and you need sound right so you
need some kind of
feedback that if the ball bounces back
and forth you can get some sound effect
that tell you what's going on so you
always need these three things in order
to even do the very very simplest things
so what I would like to I would like to
live in a world where we can do this and
standard C++ where you can take a
compiler out of the box you can build
something like this with it where are we
today so question to the room can you
write a C++ program today just using
standard C++ that makes sound doesn't
matter like can you make a portable yes
yes you have the Bell camera so you can
try this if you I mean I tried it on my
macbook an hour ago it actually does
make prep right so and probably on Linux
on Windows is gonna do the same so we
can actually make sound and C++ today
without any third party stuff okay let's
let's go back to this is this enough to
to do this it turns out not quite so in
order to do even this you already need
two different sounds all right so you
need one sound if you successfully if
the if you hit the ball successfully and
you need a different sound of the ball
you know goes off the edge and and you
lose so you need two different sounds
for that so you can't even do this in
standard C++ I think we can do a bit
better and actually we are doing a bit
better because obviously audio is widely
used in C++ today so how do we do that
so first of all all these operating
systems they give you native audio API
right so and we notice you have a bunch
of them you have paws RP you have a 0
you have direct sound some of them are
deprecated on on Apple operating systems
you have core audio which is there some
framework or Linux again you have a
bunch of options with Elsa probably
being kind of the lowest level and most
widely available one and then Android or
again have a bunch of api's that you can
use and then if you want to do
cross-platform stuff which
see what you want to do if you want to
use C++ or a lot of us want then there's
a bunch of cross-platform middleware and
then that this is what you will need to
use if you want to do sound across
different operating systems and
depending on you know your industry and
what kind of application you're
developing you're going to use different
things so there's some general purpose
things like SDL put audio if you're into
games you probably going to use
something like f mode or wise if you're
in Pro Audio which is kind of my domain
the most popular one is juice a lot of
companies don't use use they have their
own in-house frameworks that basically
do these things interesting is that many
of these API is both the native and the
the kind of middleware ones are actually
not C++ but they're C or if they're C++
they're kind of more like C++ 98 kind of
stuff or some of them an Android are
even Java API and the I would really
interesting thing about all of these API
is that at the low level what happens
kind of inside is always the same like
how do you represent audio and how do
you get audio in and out of the sound
card it's pretty much the same
everywhere and the way this works hasn't
really changed since several decades so
ever since the computers became fast
enough to do audio in real time
somewhere in the 90s this hasn't really
changed so you know there's more like
different high-level things but at the
low level what's what's going on is
always the same and it feels like C++ is
the perfect language to do this alright
so here's a quote from from viana see
professor that deal with harp at a low
level and your abstract away from it
with zero overhead and it's surprising
to me that for audio you don't quite
have this because for me it's like this
is a great use case for this so we have
obviously all these audio libraries but
we don't have anything in a C++ standard
so what do we mean if you say low level
so that's if you talk about what's kind
of the lowest lowest level if you talk
about
Audio on a computer so obviously what is
audio let's start with sound waves if
you have something vibrating like this
tuning fork here then this is going to
push the air and then what basically
sound is is like traveling waves of
variations in air pressure right and
then when we hear this we have this ear
and then what happens basically is that
these waves that consist of variations
of air pressure is going to hit our
eardrum the eardrums going to vibrate
and that's going to excite all these
different bones and then the signals
going to go into the cochlea and then
it's going to be picked up by these
nerves and eventually it's going to
arrive in our brain so this idea with
the waves and kind of the membrane if
you go to the computer world the
microphone pretty much works the same
way you know we have sound waves and
then the microphone there was a membrane
diaphragmatic vibrates pretty much like
our eardrum
the difference here only is that it's
not translating it into kind of
mechanical waves that then go into the
brain but is instead there was a coil
and it's inducing current and then it's
translating that into an electrical
signal which then goes into our sound
card and then the other way around if
you have output is pretty much the same
thing just the other way around so we
have a computer which you know admits
some electrical signal which is then
converted into an analog like analog
electrical signal and then it just goes
the other way around there's like this
coil and the magnet and then that
excites a membrane which then vibrates
and that again pushes the air and that
reproduces the sound so this is always
the principle what's going on so we have
an audio signal and we have ways of
getting it in and getting it out how do
we represent now audio data in a
computer because this is all the analog
world right it's like things vibrating
this is like physics but we are talk
about computers so if you talk about
these vibrating things then basically
what your signal is it's basically the
amplitude of that vibration over time so
this is what an audio signal is it's
just a quantity over time which is the
amplitude
and you can represent it in whatever way
current and in the computer obviously
you want to represent it digitally so
you want to represent it with bits and
bytes and the way to do this is by
sampling so this is I think not very
surprising to anyone if you have a
continuous signal which various some
kind of quantity then you're going to
sample it and each sample is just going
to be a number something like a
floating-point number for example so
that is just a single numerical value
which represents the amplitude of the
sound signal at this point in time and
this principle of doing this is called
linear pulse code modulation and this
has been around for almost a hundred
years now so if you if you look up vika
pedia so there's reference in 1920s
twenty six someone who basically
invented PCM and was using it and this
person was using five bit PCM so they
were using five bits to represent one
sample so really the only thing that
changed over the last 100 years is that
we have more bits now this is literally
the only thing that changed his
principle of representing sound
digitally in this way has been around
for a very very long time so there are
other ways of representing sound which
are sometimes used in kind of specific
applications but in the vast majority of
use cases this is the way to do it so
this we can call this the standard for
representing audio there's two
quantities here which are interesting
which is the sample rate which is how
many samples you have per second and the
other one is the bit depth which is how
many bits you have to represent a single
sample and those are interesting because
they are they basically reflect one kind
of human hearing right so the sample
rate is going to decide what frequencies
you can represent so there's this
Nyquist theorem which says that if you
have like for example 40 for 100 Hertz
which is a sample rate of a CD then the
highest frequency you can represent with
that is half of that so you can go up to
20 2015
and this is pretty much around the limit
of so the limit of human hearing goes up
to about 20,000 Hertz and then it kind
of decreases decreases as you age yeah
so it depends on the person depends on
your age but if you are if you use
something like 48 thousand Hertz so you
can go up to 24 thousand Hertz in terms
of frequencies you can encourage it's
safe to say that this way of doing it
can represent all frequencies that
humans can hear and the bit-depth is
also similar so the bit-depth basically
says what dynamic range you can
represent so if you have a bit depth of
16 bit which is the bit of a CD you can
represent about 96 decibels if you go up
to 24 bit which is kind of used in a
professional settings then you can
represent 144 Hertz I think sorry
disappointed 40 decibels and this is
around the dynamic range of the human
hearing so if you look at the faintest
sound that human ear can hear and then
on the other end of a spectrum like the
loudest kind of pain threshold before
the eardrum bursts then the the dynamic
range between those two is about 140
decibels so basically with these two
kind of quantities you can you can cover
everything that humans perceive a sound
of course because your quantizing in
both of these dimensions this means we
get artifacts and there's this nice
analogy to graphics
we're basically graphics is basically
the same just in 2d instead of 1d right
so so it's kind of sampling things and
then the sampling rate is pretty much
the kind of resolution and the bit that
is like the how many bits per cup you
have to represent the color so here if
you if you have a lower resolution you
can represent fewer details that's kind
of this axis and on this axis if you
have fewer bits for each color then
you're going to lose
you can lose kind of the different
shades of the of the colors and you have
the same kind of artifacts and sound as
well except that they manifest
themselves as audible noise or artifacts
right so we have this this is how you're
presenting all your signal one thing
that's missing is audio can be
multi-channel right so migrant this
microphone has like one channel if you
have headphones typically its stereo if
you have surround you can have six
channels so you can have even more so we
need to add to this picture the notion
of a channel so then we not only have
kind of samples over time but you also
have channels and then the other term
which is really important here is the
frame and that represents basically the
value of each channel at a certain point
in time so the terminology here is is
really important some people kind of say
sample when they actually mean frame
right sample is one number and the frame
is one number per channel so it's really
important to not confuse these two terms
all right so we have channels we have
frames you have samples we pretty much
have everything in place one thing to
say about channels channels kind of
names so it's not just channel 0 1 2 3
it's like left-right surround this
different channel layout so if you have
six channels you don't know if it's
three stereo if it's 5-1 so you know
they have this there's more to it than
just kind of having n channels and
unfortunately on on computers there's
not portable so I think on Mac is like
left right center and on Windows has
left center right or the other way
around I can never remember it but
basically the meaning of the channels is
kind of independent of the index so to
say so this is like another thing to
keep in mind right so now we have this
audio data how do we get it in get it
out of something like a computer for
that we have audio devices there's two
kinds there's actually three kinds
there's input devices like a microphone
there's output devices like speakers and
then there's devices that do both input
and output and then some of them have
one channel or two channels and then if
you are kind of professional sound
engineer you might have one of those
which has maybe 16 ins and 16 outs so
there's all kinds of devices
built-in external but they all do the
same basically they have a number of
input channels and/or a number of output
channels one thing about devices so we
said we have a sample which is a numeric
basically value what type is this value
and that also depends on the device so
so this should say desktop software not
best apart we're sorry so on desktop
software you typically represent a
sample with a floating-point number
which is conventionally between minus 1
and 1 some phones especially older ones
they use 16-bit integer other machines
might may use 8-bit integer or fixed
point so you can have different
different numeric type to represent a
sample and all these things actually can
also change it change it runtime so this
is just screenshot of my my notebooks
audio settings and you can see that you
have all these different devices some of
them are input some of them are output
then I have this get in an out kind of
aggregate device and then each one of
those devices you can choose the sample
rate like this 48 kilohertz whatever you
can choose how many samples you want and
you can choose the type the numeric type
how to represent a sample so all these
things you can they can change at
runtime right this is this is important
because it's not just like a type def
somewhere they can change it runtime so
if you have a notebook typically if you
have you can have multiple devices like
right now for example I have a
microphone speakers HDMI connected and
headphone out typically if you have
something like Mac OS Windows Linux then
one of these devices will typically be
the default input and one of them will
be the default output and you can
typically choose which one you want to
use or an app might just use the default
or an app if you have a more advanced
audio app than you might the user might
be able to choose which device they're
going to use that for example if you
have something like I don't know Skype
then you can go into the preferences and
choose a device which is
not necessarily the one that's
configured in the operating system
settings and then the device
configuration changes run time right so
you can I can yank out this cable and
then this device is going to disappear
and then you know an app needs to handle
that in a reasonable way and for example
here's this is like discord so if you
plug something in some devices will
detect that something happen and we'll
suggest to you well do you want to
switch the device others will just use
the default yet others I mean there's
different ways you can handle this but
the important thing is that there are
all these different devices and they
change you might have more stuff so the
operating system might have kind of a
mixer or other effects going on you have
typically like a global kind of volume
setting and then this is kind of a more
advanced feature some kind of driver api
is allow you to use exclusive mode which
means that if you have an app it's going
to be the only app that's talking to the
sound card and then you're going to be
directly writing out basically the
signal that goes out to the speakers the
normal case is the shared mode where you
have different apps running and each one
makes different sounds and then the
operating system is going to mix them
all together and that's what you're
going to get at the output and then if
you have like mobile devices like phones
there's more stuff going on so you have
these audio sessions that can iOS and
Android you have these api's where I
don't know like let's say you have a
music player going on that someone calls
you and then that has like higher
priority so this call will interrupt
your app and then if you hang up then
you know the app focus might go back to
your app or whatever so and then there's
there's this other thing where you know
for example if you record stuff there
might be some security features saying
hey do you want to allow this app to
access the microphone so there's a lot
going on here
and from like an architectural point of
view what what happens is that there's
all these different layers so at the
very bottom you have some kind of
hardware device which actually has an
audio sorry analog digital converter
then there's like a driver for this
device then this driver talks to the
kernel of T of the operating system the
operating system is doing some stuff is
grabbing
data from the heart we're writing it
into some memory somewhere or like
reading it from there and then the
opening system gives the user an API and
then the users going to talk to that API
and there's different ways of doing that
you might use one of those cost pad for
middleware frameworks which kind of just
abstraction area on top of the different
API some different platforms you might
have like a higher-level framework like
F mod which gives you and more high
level tools or you might just have an
application that directly talks to you
know the Windows Mac Linux iOS whatever
API so there's all these different
layers and different ways of doing it
but then at the end of the day you have
all your data you have these samples and
frames and channels and they go all the
way from the bottom all the way to the
top through all these layers and back
and how does that happen so if you have
a sound card each sound card has one of
these which is look what's crystal which
is a timer and then it also has some
where you know some buffer with memory
where the data goes and then what
happens is that thanks to this timer
you're going to get a call back through
all of these layers and this callback
comes in regular intervals so and and
the other thing here is that the audio
is done in in buffers so we need to add
one more thing which is kind of the last
term that we need here to this picture
so now we not only have samples and
frames and channels but you also have a
buffer which is basically chunk of this
stream and basically this is a 2d array
of numbers right so you have channels
and you have frames and basically what a
buffer is is a chunk of 2d it's a 2d
array of some numeric type that's what
it is and the reason is done in buffers
is well so you get this audio callback
and it would be very inefficient
remember the sampling rate is something
like 48 thousand frames per second so
we're very inefficient if you get 48,000
callbacks per second through all these
layers that would not be possible so
what you get is you get fewer callbacks
and each call
giving you a chunk now here's a
trade-off here because if basically if
you use bigger buffers then you have
like less it's less expensive to do you
have less calls so you're going to
consume less CPU but you're going to
introduce more latency right because
you're buffering so the bigger the
buffer is the more latency you're gonna
have and if you're just playing back a
file like a music file maybe doesn't
matter but if you're if you're
performing music for example you're
playing a keyboard you want you expect
your notebook to play what you're
playing the latency is really annoying
like the latency of like 30 milliseconds
or 50 milliseconds or something that
you're going to notice if you if you
play you keyboard so it's really
important to keep this latency down so
typical values for these buffers are
something like 128 samples 256 samples
or 64 samples if you really want to have
like low latency and that means you're
gonna get a callback every one or two
milliseconds something around that this
is kind of the the timeframe we're
talking about and this is actually
typically if you have like a more kind
of professional audio application this
is a creature of Fable life then you can
set this buffer size and then you can
choose this trade-off between kind of
CPU load and latency so one more thing
about these buffers so we said it's a 2d
array 2-d arrays have two ways you can
order them right this row major order
and column major order like which
dimension around the same with audio
except that we call them differently so
we have let's say we have two channels
left and right so there's these two
different ways of doing it you can have
an interleaved platform which basically
means it's frames first so you're gonna
have channel 0 1001 and that's your
first frame it and channel 2 channel 3
this is the second frame or you can do
it the other way around where you have
like this would be a buffer with 4
frames and then you have all the all the
samples for the first channel and then
all the samples for the second channel
so these are the two different ways of
doing it and then this callback that
you're getting from the sound card
you're gonna get to read this buffer if
it's input or you gonna write into the
buffer if it's output and this looks
something like this so this is how you
would write called
one of those middleware frameworks so
you get this callback which is just a
function you get like a pointer to a
pointer to like the input buffer and a
pointer to a pointer the output buffer
so it's like a 2d 2d array remember and
then it's gonna tell you how many
channels you have and how many frames
you have and then you can fill that
buffer so here for example you would
this is like a very simple algorithm
they just write like a sine wave which
is just like babe like a very boring
kind of tone with stable frequency so
you're doing kind of a sine wave so you
just generate you looping over the
frames and over the channels and you're
just writing numbers into this into this
array and this is how like at the
low-level how it's often done so this is
kind of I mean in 2019 kind of looks
maybe a bit ugly so that's like a rule
pointers to pointers there's a lot of
parameters this is basically C code
right so a lot of all your code is
written this way where it's kind of C++
but the actual code is like C compatible
the C++ compiler or maybe a few C++
features but a lot of people write code
this way so which is why I think you
know it's important to maybe think about
whether we can get people or more more
more than API is to do this kind of
stuff and one more important thing about
this audio callback so you're going to
get this callback through all these
layers of api's every I don't know one
two milliseconds the important thing is
that this is a high priority operation
because what happens if you miss one of
these buffers that you get a callback
and you have like one millisecond to
write a buffer and you don't do that
like for example you there's an error or
something takes too long and then you
miss one of those callbacks and you get
the next one before you've written the
buffer that's going to be sent it's all
real time stuff right so it's going to
be sent to the speaker so you're gonna
have garbage values or maybe no values
being sent to the speaker's being
converted to actual sound and you're
gonna get them you're gonna hear them so
that's going to be a dropout or a click
or some other artifact and turns out
that the human ear is really sensitive
to kind of inconsistencies in
continuities is that the English word in
continuities and the only audio signal
discontinuities yeah thank you so
if for example you're writing these
buffers and we miss a single sample
you're gonna hear that as a click so
it's really important that if you end us
in this callback where you're writing
stuff into this buffer you're never
going to miss a sample you cannot fail
because then you know if you have some
kind of music app going on and then it
has a clicks and glitches no one's going
to use it so so this is what your
callback stuff is typically what we call
near-real-time it's not like so it's not
exactly the definition of a real-time
system like an airplane or something
because you still have an operating
system going on you still have like a
thread scheduler but typically the stuff
will run on a high priorities read and
you only have something like 1 or 2
milliseconds to to produce your data and
you cannot fail
which means you said you cannot fail you
said that you have to program in a very
specific way inside this callback you
can't use locks on you Texas yes so the
question was why is the why do we not
write to volatile data and well the
answer is that it's not directly the
hardware it's not like directly the the
memory of the sound card directly mapped
into your memory there is there is a
layer in between you are typically in
the kernel space of the operating system
there's going to be some extra buffering
going on so typically you have like the
actual hardware a sound card buffer and
then the operating system will kind of
copy things out into another buffer and
there's some stuff going on under the
hood so that the the buffer that you get
as a user is not the actual volatile
Hardware buffer on an embedded system
that would be different an embedded
system that this would probably be
volatile but the code I showed it's kind
of stuff that would run on an on a
desktop yeah ok cool so we are in this
near real-time world which means tablets
just gone out so I don't know what time
it is
oh I know okay man typed up shows me
what time it is good
so we can't use mutexes we can't use
locks because if you're waiting for
another thread first of all you don't
know how long it's going to take
second of all the threat we're waiting
for might have a lower priority so you
get this priority inversion thing where
the high priority thread is waiting for
a low priority thread and then higher
threat will actually kind of be
effectively low priority and then this
whole thing could be scheduled out by
the scheduler and then it could schedule
something else instead and then you're
gonna get an audio dropout that's not
good so you can't use locks you can't
allocate memory because that's the same
thing you don't know how long it's gonna
take you obviously can't do any file or
network input/output or even see out or
anything like that on the audio thread
because that's you don't know how long
it's gonna take it's typically going to
be a non-deterministic retimed blocking
operation you basically can't call any
code where you don't know how long it's
gonna take so you can't call into any
third party API typically unless you
know it says this is safe to call in
this real-time context so what you're
going to be doing here because obviously
if you have this processing thread going
on you need to get data in and out of
your of your processing right so what
you're going to end up doing is you're
gonna have to do block reprogramming
you're gonna use the Tom Mix you're
gonna use lock free cues lock free
structures those are essential tools if
you do local level or do coding so this
is kind of the world that all you
developers live in which is why you know
C++ is good because it gives us these
tools C++ is not itself explicitly like
a real time safe language like an you
can't say in C++ okay this function you
know it's declared to not take longer
than a millisecond you can't do that in
C++ but C plus gives you tools so you
can ensure these things via the way you
write code because you know we don't
have a garbage collector we do have a
Tom Mix and all these things etc okay so
um but you know this is kind of the
low-level but a lot of people who are
not kind of professional you developers
when they see this they say oh this is
so I don't really care about this stuff
you know this is all this happens under
the hood I don't care about this you
know what I want I want to be able to do
this so this is what like most of the
time if I talk about the stuff to like
non audio
people this is what they say I don't
care I just want this give me this and
then I'm gonna be happy well so how'd it
be how do we do this how do we actually
play back a file so now we talked about
how kind of how it works so now think
about it it you know it looks like it
should be the simplest thing but what do
we need to make this happen okay so
first of all you have this audio
processing frame we talked about this
right so we have this actual sound card
which an actual kind of timer going on
and you get this real-time call back
then you get like a buffer you generate
some samples you probably need to
resample them for example if you play
back a file and then the file is you
know recorded in one sample rate and
your machine is configured to another
sample rate need to resample it so even
just to play back a file there's going
to be some number crunching going on
then you need to keep it between minus 1
and 1 because then you get otherwise you
get glitches again or you get
distortions so you need to kind of clip
it so you have all this number crunching
going on in the end you have to write
the result into this buffer and then so
this is how you kind of push the data
out to the speakers and then the data
comes from a file because we are playing
back a file so what you need to do is
you need to read the actual file the
actual WAV file or a piece for whatever
you have in 2d code because it's not raw
samples it's not the format we discussed
it's some kind of compressed format or
at least kind of packaged up in the
source in some way so you need to
actually decode it do a lot more number
crunching if it's a compressed format
and you can't do that on the audio
processing thread right because this is
file i/o this is like non-deterministic
it's not real-time safe so the question
is how do we how do we connect these two
right to just even playback a simple
file and the answer is well you need to
buffer it you need to have a lock free
buffer right so you're going to read the
file on one thread decode the way for
mp3 or whatever and then you get these
frames and buffers you push them to this
so this buffer this is not the audio
buffer it's like the word buffer here I
use in terms of what I mean is a block
free block free FIFO right so you push
some samples onto this FIFO and then on
the other on the
think that you you pull you pop them so
this way it's locked free and this is
you have to do all the stuff in order to
just play back a file now the
interesting bit is you can do almost all
of the stuff portably in standard C++
today right
so to decode a WAV file maybe you want
to use some library but at the end
you're just reading from a file and
you're doing some numeric operations
locked Riku we can write that in C++
it's there's one in boost you know
there's all the all the rest we can do
that the only bit that we cannot do
portably in C++ today is this we cannot
read and write from into an audio device
without using basically third-party
libraries that talk to proprietary
native non platform basically
platform-specific api's so this is the
one bit that is not portably doable and
super starts today unless you use
proprietary software which which is
going to be outside of the scope of the
standard because you know you're talking
to some operating system specific API so
I think this is unfortunate because you
know we got filesystem now in the
standard we got Network we will get at
some point hopefully networking in the
standard and this is another one of
those you know input/output things which
is just not portably doable today so the
question is does that belong in the
standard library and this is from I
think some slides from Bryce who's the
loogie chair and the committee where
they had this discussion about what
belongs in the standard library well
okay so then denies exists in practice
right so things that belong the standard
are things that have been designed
they're not going to change there's not
going to be any groundbreaking changes
and what the way it's done stuff that
people have implemented that people have
experienced where people have used
and then things that go into Senate I
would need to address a clear need so
either they're like very very commonly
used functionality like a vector or it
in kept encapsulates no portability like
file system networking etc what's
difficult to implement correctly or it
requires language support and if you
look at audio it certainly fits all of
these boxes and it certainly also takes
those two boxes so again if you look at
this quote I think this low level is a
good candidate for the C++ standard
library which brings me to the next
section of a talk which is a proposal to
do just that so um this is kind of maybe
I have some time to kind of tell a
little bit the story about this so I did
talk about how you do audio in C++ like
in general ah at CPP 1 2015 and then I
was kind of after that I was thinking
like in back of my head I had this this
thing that maybe you know someone
someone should write a proposal like
this but I didn't have time to to do it
and then I thought ah the committee is
not going to be it's like too niche
anyway so I didn't spend time on this
and then in 2016 I I joined the C was
passed an ad committee and I met guy
Davidson whom some of you might know who
is the author of the graphics 2d one of
the authors of the 2d graphics proposal
which is another one of those things
that are not portably doable in C++
today and and we started talking and we
started talking about audio somehow
because kind of he said graphics kind of
user input and audio there are kind of
three things you need to basically do
even the simplest kind of app and then
you said hey there was this other guy
whose name is also guy guy's sunberg who
is thinking about proposing audio for
the standard library and and I was like
yeah yeah I was thinking about the same
thing so maybe we should we should meet
we should talk about this and it was
really nice because guys Samberg so we
then started
talking exchanging emails turned out
guys Samberg is one of the world's
leading experts on audio for video games
he actually wrote two books about audio
for video games I know nothing about
video games I'm a kind of professional
kind of music software person so so we
came from two different industries and
we both wanted to do this API and then
we started designing it on the fly sort
of so to say and then it turned out yeah
be both kind of coming from these
completely different directions we both
agree with the lower level is this is
basically what I've talked about for the
last half hour this is kind of if you
have that you can do everything else on
top in a portable way so you just need
to standardize this kind of this low
level and then and then basically you
have everything or you can do everything
um so then we kind of started designing
this API and then basically the idea was
let's not invent anything that's not
come up with something new let's just
take all these like cross-platform
middleware libraries that already do
this
since decades and let's kind of find
just the common denominator and and
maybe write that down and kind of move
what on C++ and and that's going to be
this API so there's no kind of really
new it's not really something new it's
basically like taking all the existing
practice together and kind of finding
like the most kind of common common
denominator and then you know
translating that into a modern C++ API
so this is what you've done and you
presented this at the audio developer
conference in November 2018
for the first time which is a conference
for pro audio people and there were
these are the three of us presenting
this and there were a bunch of people in
the room it was packed and everyone said
yeah we like this this is really cool
you said yeah we have all these like we
are writing all these like libraries
that talk to these devices and all these
platforms you have to maintain all the
stuff it's really annoying like wouldn't
it be nice if you wouldn't have to do
that or we have to like you know buy
proprietary software to do this wouldn't
it be nice if it came with the compiler
for free so everyone was kind of super
happy with this direction which was you
know not expected I thought maybe the
reception would not be as positive but
it was so that was good so
and the other thing that also happened
in November so if you know kind of how
the see past us committee's organized
they have kind of these main groups
actually now they have also the two
incubator groups they're missing here
anyway it doesn't matter the green boxes
are the different study groups for kind
of industry specific areas and there's
one here which is SG 13 which is the
study group for human machine
interaction and input-output and they
met also in November in San Diego at the
committee meeting I was there they were
mainly talking about the 2d graphics
proposal and the kind of data saturation
of that but then there was a little bit
of time I left and I was in the room and
I said hey you know me and these two
other guys it's funny because I say guys
but they're both actually called guys so
they're there so this is one of the
instances where it's actually okay to
say guys because they're both literally
called guy so when I write emails I also
say I would say hi guys and I start with
the capital G so that joke never gets
old so these two guys they were not
there but I was there and I said hey you
know we're thinking about writing this
up
would this be interesting for you is
this something that you know belongs in
the study group do you even think
there's a possibility we could consider
this and then the people in room said
yes we want this this is cool please
write it up and bring it to the next
committee meeting and then we did that
so we wrote the first revision of this
proposal which is basically proposing a
standard Audio API for C++ this it's not
like formal wording yet it's more kind
of like the design kind of and and we
presented this r0 this kind of first
revision at the next meeting which was
in February in Kona
in Hawaii beautiful place unfortunately
you don't get to really explore any of
the stuff because you're stuck in a room
like this for six days looking at code
but so you presented this r0 version
there and again reception was positive
he actually plans it both in HD 13 and
in lugi and it was interesting because
there's no other there were no other
audio experts in
but there were a lot of standard library
experts and they again gave us a lot of
feedback on the API and how to make it
such that it fits better into the
standard library and yeah so with all
that feedback you know we returned from
Hawaii and wrote up r1 which is in the
post Kona mailing so that's the one
that's currently online if you go to WG
21 that dot link slash P 1386 you're
gonna get this this is not the newest
revision yep
because there's going to be an upcoming
meeting in Cologne in July and there
we're going to present the next revision
because we got more feedback on this and
we solve more problems so another thing
that happened in Kona is that we got
feedback from one of the big kind of
operating system slash hardware vendors
who do have a very good audio stack and
they gave us a feedback about you know
if they were to implement this API for
their system you know maybe we should
kind of change this and add this and
this other thing that's really important
that we all looked so we took all these
feedback and now be in the process of
writing up the r2 which is the third
revision of this and this is the one
that we're going to be presenting in
Cologne two months from now and it
starts to look really good and it's not
just like made-up API on paper you
actually have a reference implementation
of all the stuff it's not not everything
they have on the slides is in there yet
it's kind of a bit like about a month
out of date but it works it works on Mac
OS currently we didn't write the Windows
or Linux implementations yet but we hope
to do so before cologne and if anyone
wants to help please so yes this works
you're gonna show we're gonna see some
code later actually running code this is
public you can check it out so the next
half an hour so I will go through this
API and also kind of highlight the
latest changes that we have in r2 so
basically this API it's simple it's a
small library the the Mac OS
implementation of this whole thing is
like about five hundred lines of code
now so it's really
not that much so we have basically these
four classes we have the audio buffer
which is what we saw is kind of the data
structure that we need we have the audio
device which is the handle to the to the
sound card we have this class audio
device IO which is we're gonna see later
what that is and then we have all the
device list which is a list of the audio
devices you have available obviously so
we only have these four classes the
audio buffer looks like this so
basically it has a size and we have
these four sized functions maybe you
don't need all four of them not sure yet
but basically you can get you can
basically ask you know how many samples
frames channels are in the buffer and
then you have to operate a / m / n which
can access a single sample by frame and
by channel so it's a bit like a 2d span
sort of thing essentially it's not
owning it's like a just a kind of a span
like wrapper around this kind of 2d data
structure that holds the audio data that
you want to read and write okay
by the way if anyone has questions just
feel free to interrupt me this is kind
of not a problem
so yes yeah yes this is both why I mean
if it's readable then you know we can
make it Const like there is I don't see
a value in having like a different type
for a read buffer and the write buffer
because the the same kind of data so I
don't see value in that distinction like
other for example core audio that was
just the the Mac API it doesn't
distinguish between them I think most
other api's don't in terms of just the
datatype that you use yeah I mean maybe
there's a good reason that I've
overlooked why we should have but I'm
not aware of one yes Casper
yes there is the question was why do we
not call it audio : : buffer but audio
and Escobar actually in r0 it was audio
: : buffer and then there were some
comments from titus specifically who has
a paper on this about her nested
namespaces are bad and why they're good
reasons not to use them and I don't have
time to talk about this but there was a
paper from titus winters talking about
the stuff so there are good reasons why
we then chosen our one to switch from
audio : : 2 audio underscore and have it
all in flatten names pasted so yes i'm
jay yes you gonna talk about this later
so yeah there is no integrator interface
there's just this operator thing which
is basically the same interfaces md span
which is not in C passes 20 unfortunate
it just didn't make it but hopefully
we're gonna get it in Siebel system 83
which is mb span is basically a
multi-dimensional version of span and it
has the same interface it has this kind
of operator : : sorry operator per
ampere and it has no iterator interface
there's reasons for that we're gonna
come to that later so this is similar to
mb span and in this sense right
the second important class is the only
device which is that your handle to the
actual sound cut you're gonna be talking
to so what do we need every device has a
name right if you if you look into your
settings is going to say something like
you know microphone input or like
default output or whatever or like the
name of your sound card so it has a
human readable name which is a string
and then that's not quite enough because
you can for example have two if you're
like an external audio interface you can
have two of the same kind and they would
on some platforms they might have the
same name but you still have to
distinguish them so they also need IDs
so every device also has a unique ID the
the concrete-like integer type to
represent this is not important it's
like some integer type
and then it has these properties so it's
either an input device or an output
device or both and it has some input
channels or some output channels or both
so if isn't put as false then get num
input channels going to be 0 nothing
surprising here right then it has some
of these properties so it has a sample
rate
all right so sample rate that's actually
interesting so you would think sample
rate would be an integer but actually on
some platforms it's a it's a double so
we say okay this is just a type some
numeric type so you can obviously get
the sample rate you can set the sample
rate and then not every possible sample
rate is supported typically you only
have like three or four options so you
want to be able to basically query which
ones are supported and then maybe you
can display them as options or whatever
and then the same stuff for the buffer
size so this is another property that
went up set and get again nothing
surprising here and then how do you
actually talk to it so we said it's kind
of this kind of cool back threat stuff
going on so you need to be able to start
the device and stop it and see if it's
running and now this is kind of if you
used to kind of error I and C++ this
might be weird you might expect that you
want to start the device in the
constructor and then stop at an early
structure and actually does stop in the
instructor but there's reasons why you
don't want it to start immediately
there's reasons why for example you want
to get the device get a handle to this
device and ask it ok can you use this
sample rate can you do this can you do
that and then set the parameters in the
way you want and then start it and this
is how it is in the published version
and the r-1 version turns out this is
not quite what we need here because this
doesn't work so an interesting property
is that even if you say okay give me
this sample rate I want to work with the
sample rate the device might still say
no like hey I decided that now I don't
support this sample rate anymore so so
you can ask it to do like forty-four
thousand Hertz or 4400 Hertz but then it
can still decide to do 48,000 hurt
instead
but basically when you call start what's
going to happen is it's going to start
calling your cool back but then if you
have like code that's actually
generating sound or even just patting
back a file that depends on the sampler
you need to know the sample rate before
you start doing any processing which
means well okay so we can set the sample
rate and say I want the sample rate but
then if you actually do start
what you need is need to call back and
then the device is going to start and
that's typically going to happen another
thread or some on some systems is going
to happen on the thread and then on this
other thread the device is going to
actually start actually decide what
sempre it's gonna be and then you need a
callback where you can say okay what's
now your actual sample rate okay now I
can actually set up my objects do my
kind of kind of set up stuff and after
that I'm ready to do processing and then
the device starts calling your callback
so this is why I need the started stuff
and you need to also stop callback as
well because you won't want to clean up
some of your resources and you might ask
yourself why is this stopped callback
not in the stop function and the reason
this the device might stop not only when
you stop with yourself but also if you
just yank out the cable or something
else changes on your system device might
stop before like you can't control that
and and so you need to get this
asynchronous callback when that happened
and so then the question is what is this
type and so the first consideration was
maybe should just be a state function
right because that suppose everything
then actually there was a discussion on
the committee reflector about how we
should do these things because there is
currently in supers has no accepted way
of this is how callbacks work in C++
there's like a few places in the
standard where we have something like
callbacks but not really like this not
in an asynchronous way so there's no
standard yet for how we do is
synchronous callbacks there was some
work being done like for networking for
executives but this is really kind of
different for a number of reasons like
for example what the kind of async
people do is
they have kind of more sophisticated
ways of doing callbacks where you can
kind of control whether it's synchronous
or asynchronous and you cannot kind of
control you know whether you can
synchronize it locks and also there's a
way of getting errors none of this is
needed for audio because you don't
control what thread this is going to be
on you're not going to want to use any
locks and root access or any
synchronization implicitly and also
errors you don't really need errors
because well if the device didn't start
you just don't get the callback so so
this is much much simpler but anyway
like what should this type be so sort
function is probably not good in
sequences 20 if you're going to get this
new one any in vocable which is
essentially a basically non copyable
function and plus a few bug fixes it's
this this paper so this looks better but
still you know it's going to allocate
memory and blah blah blah and you know
maybe the way you store this callback in
the device is actually in implementation
detail and what we should be doing is
something like this where it's just a
template and that's going to match an
equal level now the problem here is that
now we lost the information what kind of
function it should be what kind of koala
but should be what parameters does it
take and please correct me if I'm wrong
but I believe the solution to this and C
plus 20 is to just introduce a concept
for that and saying we have a concept
and we have this audio device callback
which is like any in vocables it takes
basically this kind of parameter and
then you just have this you just take
one of the you just take any type that
matches this concept unfortunately I
have to write template blah blah blah
requires because this is this case where
we have the same concept twice but they
can actually be different types
you can't express this with the
shorthand syntax so this is an example
where you need the long form
oh yes you're right so I can actually
write what you do a school back
autostart or you must go back auto stop
and they can yes of course
thank you yes okay so you don't need
this long form you can just write it
shorter great but this is essentially
what you need to do and I think this is
the correct way of doing these cool bags
please correct me if anyone has a
different opinion on this because this
is really important that's an
implementation detail I will probably
use this student vocable but internally
you don't gonna see it as a user I think
that's the correct way of doing it
Michael yes so this would have owning
semantics like if you so so if you have
a I don't know some kind of lambda
whatever you just give it to the device
and advise gonna store that internally
well it means you're gonna get it by ref
ref which is exactly what happens here
you don't want to own and copy just want
to move it in Michael let's discuss it
let's discuss it later so so yeah maybe
maybe this is not the only way of doing
it okay I think this is the right way
okay cool
if you don't think it's the right way
let's discuss it later because you only
have 30 minutes left and there's a lot
of slides okay so so now we can start
the device we can get a started sub cool
bag the next thing is we need to
exchange data with the device right so
we need to exchange actually buffers how
does this work and for this we have this
type audio device IO I think in the
published version it's called something
different but now it's called all your
device IO also it what's called all your
device buffers with an S now it's called
audio device IO and this basically
contains all the data is it going to be
changing with the device and in the
published version of the paper in r1 it
just contains basically your input
buffer and your output buffer and
typically you're only going to get one
of those but in some cases you can get
both if it's an input and output device
so this is why they're optional and this
is an r1 and then one of the pieces of
feedback we got from from vendors is
that well you're missing a very
important use case here which is your
missing timestamps and they're really
important like for example if you just
want to play back a file doesn't matter
but what happens if you have audio that
you want to sync that to some video
right you need to know when the current
buffer that you're filling when like the
time when it will be put outside of
speakers like the presentation time and
equally if you have input you want to
know at what point in time this input
was physically received by your device
right and those are different right so
the input time will be before now and
the presentation time will be after now
imagine also if you have kind of input
and output going on imagine we have
something like you know you're talking
into your microphone and then that goes
out the speakers so it has kind of
round-trip latency and then you want to
you want to do a feedback suppression so
you need to kind of know what the
latency of your system is right which is
why in our tube he introduced timestamps
and this was going to be the time when
the buffer was received and the time
which is the system's best idea of what
the presentation time of this buffer of
the upper half is going to be and
they're also both optional because you
might be on a system where you don't
have that information yeah so that's the
audio device I hope to us this is what
you're getting your callback so this is
the second type of pull back it's the
audio i/o pull back and that's the
really important callback that's the one
that you actually use to do
so what you can do with this device is
you can say hey I want to connect this
callback and that's going to be the
actual processing callback the the thing
that actually makes sound and then that
is has this signature and here I'm using
the short-form syntax and i'm going to
use that in the other one as well this
is really nice I love this feature
between changes the way you design
library API it's wonderful so this is a
callback that takes reference to a
device because you might want to ask the
device what it is and and then it takes
reference to this audio device i/o which
contains the buffers into timestamps and
this is this is what you're gonna get
you're gonna see that in actual code in
a minute but yeah so this is kind of the
most important call you have one of
these callbacks which is actually doing
stuff and then you say connect this to
the audio device and then what happens
here in this case is if you call connect
the operating system is going to under
the cover spool up real time processing
thread and then it's going to start
cooling this callback on this other
processing thread which is happening
under the hood so the operating system
controls that so this is not the only
way to do audio for example core audio
and mackan and iOS works like this where
you don't have any control over this
thread it's the thread owned by the
system somewhere and the only thing you
can do is here's my callback and then
you're gonna get cool to this other
thread on wasabi which is one of the
windows API so it's a bit different
there you create this process in fact
yourself and then yourself responsible
for saying this has high priority and
then you are you are controlling the
thread so there's these two ways of
doing it which is kind of push and pull
based and in the pull based processing
you control the thread and you say okay
wait until the next buffer arrives and
then cool process so call this callback
with the new buffer and now it's the ref
it's not a ref ref so now it's it's not
owning because you own the callback and
you're just kind of like wait and block
until you know there's new data or until
there's it's time to write out the next
block of data and then you have to
manually call process to do that and you
do that in a loop so you have like a
wait process loop so this is the other
way of doing audio iron
and you kind of need to support both
because for example on a Mac you cannot
do wait process because you don't
control the thread conversely on an
embedded system but you might not have
threads the system might not be able to
even spool up a thread under the covers
the only thing you might have is the
other one to it you can only do wait
process and maybe then even wait will be
a no op and you just directly to process
so this read appends on a system cache
[Music]
so the comment was instead of having the
blocking weights have a non-blocking
check whether there's data or not and
yeah maybe you should add that it's not
really a thing on kind of desktop and
and phones but if you only have
wonderful period like on an embedded
system then maybe that's useful addition
thank you for this comment that's oh
that's considerate yeah it's good stuff
so just for completeness you might also
have wait for and wait until and then
again as I said some systems only
support push based and some other
systems only support pull based so you
might want to have functions which which
you can check at compile time ideally
which one of those you can use right now
the last class that we need is the
device list so this is a screenshot of
my Mac you have several devices you need
to choose need to have an API to kind of
see which devices are there and then
choose one so this is the API that that
we have which is very similar to you
know how everyone else is doing it so
you can you can ask what's the system's
default input device and default output
device that's like the one that you
would have configured here like the blue
selected one you might not have one so
which is why it's optional and you can
also say give me all available input
devices give me all the way a blow-up at
devices and then you have this kind of
would you device list which is just like
us pay
stupid list this is basically the same
API as the TZ DB list and C passes 20
which is just like a very simple kind of
you don't need any kind of elaborate
interface it just needs to be able to
iterate through it yes well so so the
woody device class is just a handle
right so if you get if you get you
iterate through it you get a device and
then in the meantime that device is gone
then you're just not going to be able to
connect or you're gonna get an error if
you try to start it or connect to it and
then you might want to say okay well
something changed that the device is not
there anymore and then handle that like
for example if we have this case where
you yank out the device while the app is
running some apps might want to do
something like this I want to explicitly
detect this case which is why you need
one more callback that's the last
callback that we need which is the or
you the rest lists callback there's a
pretty long name if anyone can come up
with the better one please let me know
but you need a callback if the list of
all your device has changes and and this
solves the problem that you just
mentioned right so if why are you
iterating through it this is all kind of
thread safe right because the handle if
the device goes away like the handle
it's kind of still there while you
iterate through the list because you get
this list this list is going to be
stable this is not racy but then why are
you doing that you might get this
callback and then you might want to
throw away the list and get a new
version of the list and then iterate
that again implementation defined thread
when something changes you don't know
how it's going to be called this is
nothing to with processing this is just
this is kind of be another level of the
operating system which controls what
other opportunity the app has to call
this
so if you are on the system that doesn't
have threads you typically wouldn't have
multiple devices coming and going you
would just have like this is your device
it's hardwired you're going to talk to
this buffer all the time increment ation
to find different operating systems
doing it in different ways we can't
mandate any of that oh yeah oh sorry you
the question was why does it not give
you or to make using your device list
and the answer is yeah maybe we should
have this as a as a parameter here yeah
I don't know I'm not sure I don't you
can either query it yourself or you can
just the system can pass it in into the
Colbeck cousin is an argument like a
reference to it or whatever or like
actually not a reference but maybe by
copy because so it's not racing yeah may
if you feel that's better we can do that
just these are the kinds of changes that
we still had can make yeah well you
would call the get audio input so so
there's two lists right so you might be
interested in in Bo's are one of them so
you would have to pass both of them in
and then kind of it comes along but
maybe that's better I don't know let's
let's discuss it afterwards it's not
really super important I think we can we
can do what you say I don't see yes
what are you gonna call the get audio
input device I think I think it's in my
opinion this is better put it on the
caller because you might only be
interested in one of the lists you might
not be interested in them at all because
you just have you receive this stopped
callback so maybe you just want to say
yeah okay then I'm gonna quit the app or
whatever so there's different ways you
can react to this which is why I feel
like this is kind of more open-ended but
if if there's good reasons why we should
pass the lists in you can do that too
like I don't have any strong opinion
about that and I don't want to spend too
much time on this detail because it's
not super important
yes what do you mean by revoke it later
okay well then pass in like an empty
lambda yeah yeah so if you need multiple
call backs you need to do the dispatch
yourself this is like super bare-bones
stuff you have only one callback that
you can register yeah we have 18 minutes
left and I want to do now the live
coding demo so do you want to spend more
time on this callback stuff yes yes you
know but there is an important guarantee
about the start and stop callback which
is why it needs to be asynchronous in
the first place so there's so you want
to setup and teardown stuff that you
needed a processing callback so the
really important guarantee here is that
you get the start callback before you
get the first processing hall back and
you have the other guarantees at the
point where you get the stop callback
you're guaranteed that you're not going
to get any processing callbacks anymore
so there's an ordering start callback
processing callbacks stop callback and
this is the really important ordering
because then you can't have any races
between start stop and your processing
code the the one that you mentioned I
think you would the the devices changed
callback I think typically would be done
on like the not the processing thread
but kind of some kind of main message
loops read kind of things so that would
be that would be probably no guarantees
for that particular cool bag yeah good
okay live demo let's see let's see if
that works so I'm going to switch the
display now oh this is going to go wrong
all right so this is probably very small
so I should I should it's just better
yeah I think this is better right so so
this is the library again it's on github
here it is this URL you can check it out
you can play with it that's cool it's
also very lightweight and small and
apart from some of you are two things
that I mentioned everything is in there
okay so first first app is really really
simple actually that's incorrect that's
two seconds so this is all this is
everything there is this fits on one
screen so we have this include audio
stuff which is really cool I think and
it's currently namespaced experimental
and then what happens here is okay you
have a so this is generating white noise
so this is basically just taking the
buffer and writing random numbers
between minus 1 and 1 into it so there's
not nothing complicated going on so we
need to set up our little random
generator and then we get the default
audio output device and then oh I I
didn't mention this explicitly but the
buffer has a template parameter which is
the sample type which means that the
coal bag also has the same template
parameter right so by connecting a
callback that has flowed you're saying
I'm requesting
float is a sample type yeah so that's
really cool this is how you do the kind
of runtime thing that you can have
different sample types so you're
requesting floats as the type which is
what you're going to be using anyway
that's the default on a Mac or on any a
desktop platform for that matter so and
then you connect your callback which is
just a lambda so it's just inline and so
you're just gonna check probably this so
you just come check whether the output
buffer whether there's an out buffer
this is not really necessary because you
know that you have requested an output
device so you could actually leave that
out so you're gonna get an output buffer
I'm gonna do both of frames and channels
and you're just gonna write kind of a
random number into every sample and then
if I run this this is white noise make
sound yay slightly more complicated
example this is a sine wave so it's a
little bit more code but not much it
still fits on one screen actually so
this plays a plays a sine wave where
okay same stuff but now you have a
basically like a thing that generates a
sine wave so the frequency depends on
the sample rate right so you need to do
calculate like by how much the increment
is of every new sample that depends on
the sample rate and then you're just
going to again loop over all frames get
the next value loop over all channels
and just write so we need this here
because you want to write the same value
into it into every channel right so you
can't just loop over so you need to
write it like this and if you run this
thing it's a sine wave and just to prove
that I'm not cheating
let's change this number then you're
gonna get a different frequency all
right yes
you can't even come to that um 12
minutes left need to hurry up okay a
little melody a bit more code so what
this does is it has a bunch of notes and
then it has a little synthesizer going
on which creates like a it's a very
crude and not optimal way of creating a
square wave which is typically what you
would get on old sound chips this is
still just 90 lines of code if you run
this thing it's going to play a little
melody
and you can actually write this in half
the code by using by wrapping this thing
into like a core routine instead of a
struct which is really cool but I'm not
gonna show this now so oh yeah this is
the kind of boring one print devices so
what this is going to do is just going
to do the device iteration thing so it's
just you know enumerates the devices and
tells you how they're configured so it's
kind of this thing so this this is a
little example too for for these device
lists and then the last example is
something that uses input which is the
level meter so it's a very crude way of
measuring the input volume so what this
does it rates now over the input and
kind of just calculates kind of the
average absolute value of the samples in
some regular interval and this funny
enough doesn't run in the debugger here
of sealion because apparently Mac OS the
app needs kind of like the permission to
access the microphone and somehow it
doesn't work inside the debugger I
haven't figured out yet why so if I run
this I'm not gonna get anything
interesting so I need to run this on the
in the terminal outside of the debugger
I don't know why so I'm just gonna
quickly do that right so this is now
outputting the current level and if I do
something like this you see the number
goes up so it measures the and if you
would do this in a little bit more
clever way you could have like a proper
level meter all right so these are the
examples this is the implement so this
is kind of the implementation the Mac
implementation is the staff has about
500 lines of code that's it that's the
whole thing let's go back to the slides
we don't have much time
[Music]
live demo alright alright so this is
what we have now I think this is cool
there's two problems one is someone
mentioned interleave non interleaved so
yes there are two different possible
ways how this audio buffer can be
arranged and so in our 0 we had this we
try to do this kind of iterator
interface we get an iterated through the
frames and then for each frame get
integrated for the samples or you could
do it the other way around we get an
integrated to the channels and then for
each time we get iterative samples so
you have this kind of nested iterator
thing and then they they were done in
this clever way where it just knows okay
so whether in theory that the entity was
a template parameter and then kind of so
you don't have to do it at runtime you
don't have to pay the cost for that and
then these it iterates where a set up in
this really clever way that they kind of
know how to loop over it but it turns
out it doesn't work because as soon as
you have like 2d levels of iterate as
you run into this view of views problem
which is kind of really subtle where if
you have an iterator to a frame which
itself consists of several samples this
frame itself is not an object that
exists so so you would return an
iterator to something that is not
actually an element of the underlying
container so you can't have a reference
to it you need to return by a value and
then it's not really a container anymore
a little bit like Victor pool right it's
kind of this kind of problem so so like
it just doesn't work like you could do
it with like ranges without having
containers but so what happened in Kona
is I talked to the people who
implemented MV spam because several of
them were there that was really cool
because they ran into the exact same
problem except that this is 2d and for
them it's like whatever D but it's
literally the same problem for MV span
and they just said yeah we didn't do
this we just we just have this kind of
operator access and they have operated
parameter N and they eventually want to
replace it with operator
arrey excess doesn't work currently from
multidimensional because you have if you
you can't have nested you can't really
have these nested square bracket
operators so you have a paper where we
say we deprecate the use of the comma
operator inside and 20 and then we have
that we can get the other the proper
multidimensional square bracket operator
and 23 but we are not there yet so in
the meantime we have operator per ampere
N and this is exactly what the NB span
people use
so after Kona the are one version which
is currently public we said okay screw
this iterator interface you just gonna
do MD span so would you buffer is just
going to be like a wrapper around so the
underlying thing will be just any span
it's going to have the same interface
and that was fine until we forgot
another problem which is an audio if you
have interleaved Indian to live
typically interleaved buffers are
represented like this where they're
contiguous in memory but D interlude
buffers are typically like this whether
or not contiguous in memory but you
actually have another array which has
pointers to these so it's like an array
of arrays thing but it's not necessarily
contiguous in memory and typically
interleaved would be contiguous and the
inter if it be non contiguous and then
you are facing the problem that you kind
of have to represent both interleaved
interleaf and also contiguous or pointer
to pointer all in the same type and then
we had like another template parameter
which was whether it's contiguous or not
and then it became really horrible you
can kind of do this an MD span by
hacking the like I think the fourth
template parameter mu span lets you kind
of hack around this thing but it's just
not it's not it's not really working so
so what existing audio API is do they
either do you know they say intuitive
contiguous or they say okay it's dn to
leave non contiguous and you get
pointers to pointers and practically all
audio api is just say this is what we're
using or at least they have two
different types and you can kind of
convert between the two the only one I'm
aware of that crams both this and that
into the same type as Apple which have
this audio buffer list type and it's
really I think most people don't
understand how Apple's woody bufferless
3d works it's really not obvious I
didn't understand for a very long time
so it's not something that you would
like to put in a more than C++ API so
how we solved this problem in r2 is we
just say okay we have this audio buffer
type and then the underlying layers
implementation to fine you don't care
and then also this means that you can't
create one of those because you don't
know what it is so he's gonna get this
from the system and you're gonna be able
to iterate over it
you know using this excess operator but
it's implementation to find whether how
that is stored and then if you want you
know you want to do different things
when you want it like if you want to
play back a file you want to do
interleaf because you're going by frames
if you want to do like an algorithm they
do it like an FFT you want to do it per
channel but you have like the whole
channel as a chunk and you kind of FFT
it do some stuff FF teeth back per
channel and if you want to do this kind
of stuff then what you need to do is you
need to take this and then copy it out
in the right way into one of your own
containers and there you know what the
layout is and there you can do what you
want and then you don't have a problem
it's portable it's fine yes so the
problem with this interface is that you
don't know which so there's different
ways of looping around this thing and
you don't know which way is going to be
the most efficient one so you might want
to have with some additional methods to
create that and yes maybe probably let's
talk about that later I have not decided
yet
what that would have to look like maybe
you have an idea let's talk about it
afterwards kirpan yes let's have this
conversation I'd love to have this
conversation and the next problem is
more nasty problem where so on some
systems like Windows and this is
get a screenshot from Ableton Live on
some systems like Windows you have more
than one API you can talk to right and
Andi and they have different properties
like on window specifically you have
azio which is kind of the older API
which basically offers you lower latency
which which makes it's important right
it's this important property but then
not all sound cards might have an azo
driver so then you have the kind of
manure api's which support more devices
but then they have basically not quite
as good performance characteristics so
if you're doing professional audio stuff
you might want to choose which driver
api you want to use and then each one of
those comes with its own device list
right so and then also you might know
you might have these different drivers
and you might have even another driver
which kind of a null driver which just
does nothing so so you have like one
more level right you have kind of
devices a list of devices and then you
have a list of drivers and each one have
a list of devices and you can do this at
runtime this is what like for example
juice does it's like a runtime thing why
you iterate through you can iterate
through the different drivers and then
but then it it's not really C++ e in a
standard DS kind of way so what we try
to do is you try to do it at compile
time where well okay so we have these
like not driver types and then basically
you have like a default driver which is
you know going to be one of those and
then you have the other ones which I can
fermentation define and then the audio
device now is a template on the driver
type so you can do that runtime or
compile time right so if you do that
compile time if you do run time you're
gonna have pretty morphism and all the
stuff you do a compile time you're gonna
have this and then the device is going
to have a template parameter which is
the driver type the device list is going
to have a driver type a parameter the
this whole API every one of those
methods will have a driver type template
parameter and this trickles through the
whole API right because every driver
might have a different clock type so
your time stamps might have different
types so your buffer needs to have a
driver template parameter as well and
then that trickles through the callback
so now you're writing the callback you
need to know what driver type you're
writing against and this kind of defeats
the purpose of writing portable code
like we try to do this this is what we
have in in our one but in the repository
which is online now we rip the DeWalt
again we're not going to do this because
we like this doesn't work it results in
an API that's and then you need to come
up with yet another API to loop through
these drivers at compile time at runtime
do you define like a tuple off of
available drivers how do you loop
through it it becomes horrible or you do
this whole thing at runtime and then
you're not but like a runtime
polymorphism kind of API which is also
not nice and then so what we want to do
is you want to like hide this complexity
and and we don't see an easy way of
doing this so for now you're going to
say screw all this you're not gonna do
this if you need different driver types
sorry
so can you hide the runtime array or the
runtime problem of a thing with the type
erase type erasure
I guess yeah this is what I think I
tried in my very first attempt to
implement this which didn't look nice
maybe maybe there's a better way of
doing it so the important thing is that
the vast majority of people will not
care right so this is a very very niche
thing where you have to like distinguish
these driver types so I don't want to
impose an API on 99% of people to get
this 1% case I think we're out of time
right so can I have one more minute for
just the summary so the only other big
thing that we have left that we need to
do in r2 is this kind of channel name
channel layouts API this is really
important and every handling I currently
start/stop system rule probably that's
not good like the other kind of portable
i/o ish API Slyke file system they use
stood error code so probably we should
follow suit and also use that error code
I'd love to hear comments about that
open question is do we
you can use courtiers to generate
samples it's not clear to me yet how we
can use CODIS to get input but if there
was a way to do this maybe it would be
cool to kind of have a quarantine based
API instead of this kind of old-school
callback based API because then you can
write these things that I shot a lot
more elegantly and then maybe you want
to have this I don't know yet and then
these these are the things like they're
not going to do so the mobile specific
stuff it's going to be somehow like for
example if your microphone needs access
then whenever you try to open an input
device that's when a dial-up would come
up for example but all the stuff would
be implementation defined it wouldn't be
a part of the official library API
definition and then file i/o and
algorithms this is all stuff that can be
portably done on top of this so this is
out of scope because this is just the
minimum portable layer that we need to
make all of the stuff possible for other
people to do and then this is the last
slide where should this go this is an
open question you could target an audio
TS or you could target the TS that
combines all of these things that are
kind of in flight now which is graphics
and audio and maybe we get some kind of
user mouse keyboard touch input library
as well it could go into one of the next
international standards it could
actually be I think that's completely
independent from substation it could
become a boost audio library and I think
that would be really cool I think you
know if this is kind of a I think this
kind of API that would fit well into
boost so if anyone wants to help me with
that and maybe review this library to
get it in then that would be really cool
it's not much code it's just 500 lines
of code I mean it's gonna be more if you
have Windows and Linux but the API is
not that big so it would be great to
have this as a candidate for maybe
putting this into boost and then maybe
it we should just not do any of these
things it will be just another library
on github and that's also fine so let's
talk about these things
I'll be around for this week thank you
you